M it's God
it's
it's one of our first callers and then
we're going to come back insh in the
meantime guys please we're looking for
one person to get ,000 pounds let's go
hello Salam alikum or hello brother how
you guys doing thanks for having me
thank you very much we are good how you
doing where you calling from America
yeah yeah I'm um from the West
Coast West CO that's good what's your
name Avery my name's Avery a Avery yes
yeah how you doing Avery thanks for
joining uh please tell us we were
supplicating actually to your country
may Allah make it a Muslim
country oh no I don't wish that but you
know we wish that we we are asking Allah
in this night to make your country a
Muslim country and okay okay anyways so
yeah what do we have do you have a
question for us and by the way we've got
some donations coming in I'll give
updates later yes you have a question
yeah sure so um there's a there's a
large topic that I like to go over
obviously with more knowledgeable people
um it's the subject of you know Jesus
being a Muslim obviously as a Christian
like you know we wouldn't we wouldn't
think that that was like that's far from
us and so when we get in these
conversations and Muslims like oh yeah
you know Jesus was a Muslim and stuff
like that so I was hoping maybe you guys
can touch on this and we can have a a
good back of forth on this but okay I
don't know about is he a Christian by
the way he's a Christian I don't
know is Jesus Christian that's the
question no he's not so Jesus is not
Christian yeah no so then not he
is he's a Jew he's
Israelite Israelite so and did he submit
his will to the will of
God uh I would say
yes so that's the meaning of Islam
anyone who submit his will to the will
of God is a Muslim that's the meaning of
Islam meaning of Islam the one who
submit their will to the rule of God
those are this is his Muslim yeah that's
that's that's that's our definition of
what entails a Muslim uh so that's why
we say when he's a Muslim this is what
we mean so when we say Muslim we say he
submits because he said this in the in
in the Bible you know I do not but the
will of my father so we claim that those
statements are the statements of a
Muslim that's why we say he's a
Muslim yeah yeah so I and this is the
definition that I usually get right that
the meaning of a Muslim one who submits
their will to God um
but so I but I think that there it's
it's a little bit more than that because
like for example if I were to say hey
guys I submit my will to God but my God
is a statute you guys wouldn't say that
I'm a Muslim right yeah which God we're
talking about which God you're not
exactly right right so there's a
specific it B basically has to be the
true God there's a specific concept of
God that you have to submit to and
believe in in order to be a Muslim we
would agree right yes right so so this
this is where like I like to explore
things like so like you know the god of
Islam he doesn't be nor is he begotten
um he's absolutely singular in his
Essence right you know Ted he's not a
trinity things stuff like this these are
essential identifiers of who you say God
is as a Muslim right and so yes when you
go to the Bible like do you I I don't
think that you see Jesus believing in
that concept of God that has that is not
a father has no son you know things of
this nature I think it's a little
different does he does he not where in
where in the Bible does Jesus does the
Jes does Jesus supplicate to the Holy
Spirit does he call up to the Holy
Spirit Well it's not not necessarily we
see him supplicating to the Holy Spirit
but there is a communication there okay
so who does he supplicate when he goes
to the mountain of Gethsemane for
example when he prostrates or when he's
on the cross to who uh to his father
okay good so when he's on the cross when
he's calling out for whatever it is for
that
matter yeah who he who he calling out
speak to his father okay so in Acts 2
chapter 2 22 when it says Jesus of
Nazareth a man chosen by God with with
wonderers Miracles and signs which God
did by him and he's a witness now when
we just analyze it from an outside
perspective for example when he went to
the Mount of Gethsemane he prostrates uh
when a person comes to him and says to
him oh good Master what must I do he
says there is only one good and that's
God alone so we will say that that if
somebody came to me and said Ali you are
the all knowing I said don't say that to
me Allah is the all knowing if you if
they saw me prostrating in the mountain
and prostrating they say it's prostrated
to God so these things will make us be
like hold on a second there's this
person who's always glorifying someone
bigger than him so we say that's the
characteristics of a Muslim so not only
does he say it but we judge by the
actions which is it follows to be a
Muslim that's why we deem him to be a
Muslim fromp yes
also also adding also an adding to this
since you said he Israelite he is a Jew
the Jews believe and the for example the
background that they came from they
believe in the one God for example at
that time they believe this God this God
is no is not similar to his creation God
is not a flesh according to the Old
Testament Accord God is not a flesh God
is not a body Etc and then suddenly that
you're making God into a flesh and then
suddenly all of these things you know
and actually there is another another
problem in the Bible which is when when
Jesus said the only true God is the
father what does he mean by this he said
is the father what about him before you
just answer that what was your name
Avery Avery before you just answer I
just want to give a quick update just on
the up donation just give me just one
minute yeah so donation of50 P1 pound1
from Anonymous Asim
al50 10 was it mean I mean yeah Al
so guys I'm just going to write make Dua
for Zan here subh there we go guys uh
we're just writing the names of the
donor some of donor donations are coming
in guys please carry on in we're having
a discussion with a with a Christian he
seems polite he seems reasonable we just
having a little dialogue obviously in
Ramadan we try not to get into this but
he seems reasonable we're just going to
try to continue and see where we can
come to Common understanding but please
carry on the donation guys yes uh Avery
was going to say something yes yes yes
so uh I don't want to be too long with
it there's there's a lot said I'll try
to be as succinct as I can so I could
get like your your responses so just
starting with with uh you ali um when
you're you you guys quoted you know
these verses where Jesus is praying to
the father right that he's submitting
his will to the father um and you're
saying that these you know shows that
he's you know pointing glorifying the
father giving that type of adoration to
the father yeah and so and I agree with
all of these verses I totally agree if
we're like taking taking the deity of
Christ out I don't think that you need
the deity of Christ like whether he's
God or not in order to have this
discussion of him being a Muslim like
let's let's just if I were to eliminate
that just about what he believed and
what he taught we can see if he was a
Muslim or not you know and so if he's
saying that yes he's he's praying to his
father he was sent by his father he's
the son of God in all of these
verses would would and you're saying
that in these verses it shows that he's
a Muslim my question would be then so if
these verses are showing that he's a
Muslim would you then say that Allah is
his father then since he's prostrating
to his father he's you know praying to
his father is Allah his father yeah the
wording used in the Bible is a father
but what we say is that we do not
believe go Allah is our he is our so
what we say is we don't refer to him as
the father so that phraseology that's
used in the Bible we know for example
when in the Bible it talks about the
sons of God we know it doesn't mean
literal Sons like it says Elijah is my
firstborn Israel so we know what it
means by sons is basically righteous
people righteous individuals whatever it
is for that matter so just as we don't
take the Sun as literal neither will we
take the father is the true I mean I
think you say that's fair right and and
that's see see this is where this is
this also opens this up a bit because
yes I hear everything you're saying it's
not in a literal sense but maybe in some
spiritual or metaphorical sense that God
has this fatherson relationship with His
prophets or Israel or Believers stuff
like that right but this is something
that as as you said Allah is your rub
your lord not your up right and he makes
it so clear that in no way shape or form
is he a father in any sense whether it's
literal figurative spiritual it doesn't
matter he says he's only your Lord he's
only your master and you're only you
know servants or slaves right so so
regardless of how like Jesus meant it
let's say like let's grant that he's
meaning it in a metaphorical sense it
still goes against Islam doesn't it if
he's saying he's the son of God and God
is his father even in a metaphor I think
I think there's a fundamental issue with
the understanding here which is okay
when we discuss with Christians like you
um we use your own source to explain to
you how the Divinity of Jesus Christ is
problematic from your own sources right
that doesn't mean that we believe word
for word in the current Modern Day Bible
we don't so for example simply speaking
uh from our belief we would not believe
that Allah uh spoke with His prophets in
that way that I'm your father we don't
believe that that happened in the first
place however we use these verses to
show you that no look you're saying that
Christ is divine so why is he praying
why is he doing this in your book in
your
references so that's that's the point
here that's the point that's the reason
why we refer to that because obviously
as we know I'm sure you're a of this
because you're involved in pmics that
the Bible has its own issues and we
agree with the we we we know that these
issues exist you know Bruce Meka who was
one of the you know scholars in charge
of the compilation of one of the uh
Greek New Testaments was mentioning how
you know no two are alike you know in
terms of the manuscript Traditions Etc
you have all of these you have the
earliest we have the earliest New
Testament going back to the fourth
Century which is hundreds of years after
Jesus Christ so we have uncontrolled
transmission of the Bible we have all of
these issues with the Bible we have
early church fathers differing over what
the Canon is what is actually class as
scripture so these are all issues that
the Christians have to solve for us
these are not issues for us our primary
sources in Islam are not the Bible or
the injil our primary source for our
referencing is the Quran the Sunnah
theith of the Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam so simply
speaking if Allah says something to us
in the Quran that for example Jesus said
X Y and Z and then a Christian comes to
us like you are right now and says well
Jesus didn't say that in the Bible Well
we would say we don't need Jesus to say
that in the Bible because we have our
primary sources telling that and your
Bible has problems as a source as a
primary source see you see coming from I
I understand your perspective so
obviously I would I did I have my
disagreements but I I want to make it
clear that you know I'm not coming from
an angle of Jesus Is God therefore he's
not a Muslim like I'm I'm granting that
let's let's take like I said right let's
take the deity of Christ out I don't
think that the the deity of Christ is a
subject that is necessary to determine
if we can find out if Jesus by what he
taught and believed is a Muslim or not
yes right we can just
talk the issue is Avery that you're
using the yard stick for our
conversation the scripture that you're
using as a foundational basis for our
conversation you're using the Bible say
to you we only refer to the Bible for
you we don't refer to it because we
believe in you know we don't have a
problem with saying that Jesus if
someone came to me if a Christian came
to me and said okay do you believe that
Jesus said here oh Israel the Lord our
God is one go one God Etc I would say I
don't have a problem believing that
Jesus said that I don't have a problem
actually I can believe that he did say
that yes because that's affirmed in the
Quran right yeah and he has used the
term by the way even in the Old
Testament is a unique semetic term which
means one and unique one and only let's
see let's see what he has to say so
that's the term which was used by Moses
which was used by Jesus and it is in in
in Hebrew and it is the same term was
used in Arabic language in
Quran Allah is means it's not just one
there is two one and unique there is no
second there is no third that's okay
let's just hear Aver's Point let's hear
his perspective yeah thank you guys so
um like so remember like as you I wasn't
the one who based this conversation off
of the Bible like I I wasn't the one
that brought up the Bible it was a
couple of references you know that Ali
mentioned and um um I don't know the
brother's name who was just talking uh
but but you know he he also quoted some
Bible verses that point to Jesus being a
Muslim so I'm coming from the verses
that was quoted you know to me I I
didn't I didn't go to the to the Bible
but this yeah this what I would ask this
what I would ask could we at least then
say um that according to these like
these usual famous verses Jesus
prostrating to the father Jesus saying
that he submits his will to the father
um yes they
show just to I'm not interrupting your
point just to mention here we have no
problem believing that these things
actually happen because they're in line
with our beliefs about Jesus but yeah go
ahead yeah okay so so the the submission
would be in line white right with your
belief except the theology behind his
submission because he's submitting to
what he is saying to be his father so
would you we can we say that at least
according to these verses that if we
were to take these verses as they are at
least according to these verses Jesus
isn't a Muslim theologically by way by
the way by the way I just wanted to
mention
something uh again as brother M M said
just a minute ago we are not taking the
Bible as a primary source for us our
primary source is the Quran the Quran
affirms that Jesus peace be upon Him is
Muslim affirm that he's a prophet sent
by God affirm about his miraculous birth
affirm about this those these our
primary sources so when we are when we
hear for example in other new sources
that he prostrate to God he did this is
actually airm to the same concept that
we are using we are we are using as as a
prime even though regardless if you find
the Bible even if we never read the
Bible still for us the primary source is
the Quran which is because the the
original Bible the original gospel is
already lost there is nothing out of
it's not there so for us the primary
source of the Quran and Quran affirmed
to us Jesus is a Muslim affirmed to us
he's a prophet sent by God affirmed to
us all of the information we know about
him that's all and that's this our this
our primary source when we say we're
Muslim we're using our own primary
source to to to to say this secondly
what is what the information that is
written in your scripture it affirm what
we have do you understand because um you
know I I think you do understand are you
still there yeah yeah I'm here because
we we can't see you that's why because
oh what the producers over there so we
the screen the screen is there we're
looking at the I see I see I see yeah we
can't we can't see anything that you're
doing no wores so so basically um yeah
the point I was going to make is that so
for example from our perspective yes
you're right so the wording in the
theology so it's not it's it's less the
theology it's the wording so for example
for us the father we don't believe one
of Allah's names that we have been
informed of is the father that's not one
of the names that we've been informed of
so we don't affirm that however we don't
have any other problem with the
submission part of things Etc now if a
Muslim came or a Christian came and
asked me okay so um you don't have a
problem with believing and I feel like
maybe this is what you're asking you
don't have a problem with believing that
Jesus submitted Etc but why do you have
a problem with believing that he called
him the father I would say because
that's not fundamentally in line with
our primary sources in
Arabic it's not in line with the way in
which we see it and and then if a person
asked a question okay then why why is
this happening I'd say well with the
history of the New Testament with the
history of the Bible we find this I mean
Bart Man in his book titled misquoting
Jesus he brings passages like passages
from codus one of the old manuscripts of
the Bible of the New Testament and
literally passages where people have
come rubbed out a word added a word and
then someone else has come replaced the
word and said fool and Nave don't change
scripture and and not only that not only
that just touch on one point is that
when he says a father we believe that
let's suppose that Jesus actually done
this and he was like for example he
submitted and he says who he said my
father we know in that wording is
talking about God not his father just
just as way example I give about the
sons of God it does not mean the son the
begotten son for example there's a verse
in the Bible it says Jesus is the
begotten son and the Christians come and
say well no we don't mean begotten in
that way oh we mean it in this way I
mean we have this in the Islamic
tradition where for example we have
statements of the companion
saying be Children of the that doesn't
mean yeah your children of the afterlife
right Etc so does that make sense it
doesn't mean your children it means be
people of you of yeah yeah like like I
said I I understand that it's not in a
literal sense right it's not yeah but
it's with the with the Quran it's not in
any sense whether it's metaphorical
spiritual in no sense is it ever applied
to Allah that he is a father at all in
any way shape or form this is this is my
thing so you you touched on something uh
important um my brother I I don't know
your name what's what's your name the
one sitting
say that again M mus M nice to meet
Arabic for Moses got it yeah yeah yeah
yeah for sure so Musa yeah so you you
said something important that you know
the the reason why we have in this room
in this room we have mosa we have D
David and you see we have Muhammad we
have we have you know good names we
didn't
have so so you said something that I
that I liked that that is the point of
why I'm bringing this this issue here is
that you said yes in the in these new
testament passages that you guys are
referring to you can agree that you know
Jesus submitted and prostrated and
things of this nature because those
particular things line up with Islam
however when those vers when those same
verses also say that he's submitting to
or prostrating to the father you negate
that part because it doesn't line up
with Islam and that's my
point my point is hold on let me
just just that let just that no youing
us not just that wait just let me let my
point please if I can brother there's
two things I just want to point in this
not just because they nothing Lear of
the Quran and as well there are no
historical evidences that he has said
what he has said yeah that's another
problem I mean yeah I mean okay so all
right so regardless if let's say like
because you guys are saying that these
things are now are unreliable that's you
guys have been pushing toward I I just
want to see where you're going with this
yeah you're going with so so my my thing
is is that okay so in these verses yes
he submits yes he prostrates and prays
to the father though so these that's the
part that you have to take away because
it doesn't agree with align up with
Islam which is my point if you go to the
yeah so by the New Testament if we just
look at the New Testament for what it is
the Jesus that's portrayed in the New
Testament can we agree that Jesus is not
a Muslim based off those verses that
he's no for example the question
is is this if in Islam somebody if
somebody believed in Allah yeah in every
single attribute but decid to call Allah
father is he dis believing in Allah if
he says I believe in Allah yeah
everything his his wonders his
everything but I'm going to call him
father does that commit sh does it this
is not the term that Allah has used does
it make him a one
second it's it's Innovation wouldn't it
be yeah it's Innovation okay it's
Innovation but it does not make you
disbeliever yeah it doesn't make the
point is what I wanted to say that they
used to the Arabs used to say even the
Jews used to say call
themselves what that me the children of
God oh okay not means and there is two
terms and unfortunately English is poor
language so the Latin language which is
the trans ation of it is poor language
but Hebrew and Arabic they meet in
certain things because means children
and ab means children but abna it's
about the children which is like what we
use not in a metaphorical way which
means a children or Sons or Etc but
means children of God means as a as in a
metaphorical way you understand so these
things have been used in the past so
Islam wanted to demolish this and after
the prophet was said that to leave all
of the these traces in order not to
miscot Allah in a way or another that
includes as will to prostrating to an
individuals because in the past we know
for example the brothers of Joseph they
prostrated to their brother uh and it
was something that was known that
amongst the you know to prate to someone
so when Islam came the prophet s he said
that demolish these things all things
that could lead to shik and associate
with they cut them so there is no way
someone could prostrate to someone or to
talk about God in a way that it could be
could be misquoted so that's the thing
which which is established in Islam and
adding to you because you mentioned ear
because they're not in line with the
Quran actually they are not in line with
the Old Testament for example all the
things about Jesus what you said it's
not in line with the for example the
decree the the the the Creed of the Old
Testament is not in line with it even
though the Old Testament is not a
resource for us is not something that a
primary resource for us but yet is not
in L with it adding to this that we
don't have historical evidence for
example when Jesus for example when he
said let it be not my when he was on the
crci
father who said that he has said this
tell me the ey witness that he had he
him who said I hear Jesus when he was on
the cross said that no one knows so it
was something was later on quot and they
said it was ascribed to him so the
problem is so since we don't have this
the middle you know uh uh father father
why have you forsaken me for example so
this thing who who caught him who was
there to hear him he has said that and
then what you introduce in Christianity
you
introduce a vague names like John for
example who no one knows who's John this
person they said he receives by the
because even amongst Christian Scholars
they don't know even that who's joh
who's this yeah and they say he has said
that how we know that he has said it
who's John firstly and how when he was
since John he has the one who copied
from Mark Mark didn't say what John has
said all of these things gives you in a
in a big problem actually to know you
know about the Bible to use it as as the
Prime Minister Avery I'm just going to
give you two minutes just to for your
thing because we need to R the donations
after Ramadan you can call in again but
yeah I'm gonna give you two minutes to
just answer so have your sure thank
thanks Ali I appreciate it so there
there was a lot say John John the
Apostle and a couple of women were
actually at the foot of the cross in
within hearing distance of Jesus so they
could have definitely heard Jesus say
what he said on the cross and continued
the tradition um you you said that the
the what we see uh in the New Testament
the Creed in the New Testament doesn't
match the old but it but it does when
you go to the Torah in uh Deuteronomy
chap 32:6 Moses says that Yahweh is Our
Father who created us in Deuteronomy
chapter 14 verse1 he says God says for
talking to Israel you are the children
of the most God and so you uh Isaiah
chapter 63 Isaiah chapter 61 uh God is
the father Malachi chapter 3 uh God as
the father so all throughout the Old
Testament you see that God is seen as
the heavenly father that's how he
introduces himself that's what he's
known as and it continues throughout all
the way up until Jesus's time where he
acknowledges that God is the heavenly
father and and says this is how you
should pray Father in Heaven holy is
your name so this is a consistency that
we see with the prophets all the way up
until Jesus and then we see this
disconnect with Islam where you know uh
God is not the father he's far above
that that's blasphemous and so you
shouldn't even think about it like the
heavens the Earth the mountains crumble
and Quake at the thought of Allah being
a father and having a son right you can
only be a ma he can only be your master
and you a slave so I I and I just want
to say thank you guys for letting me
come on just just to land with this
um because I I would hopefully we could
continue with the subject but yes if the
New Testament is unreliable which like
if even if I granted this like because
this is not that's not like you know
important to the subject the New
Testament was quoted to me for points
that prove that Jesus is a Muslim so I'm
just using those same verses that you
guys quoted to show how actually it
points that it shows that he's not a
Muslim that's that that was my thing he
would he would even if we went with your
argument he will still be a Muslim but
because him saying that but even if we
we're saying we don't see your text as
reliable we don't see as an we're saying
if we was to base on your text we will
say that and like just to wrap on wrap
up on this there one question Ali I
don't I don't mean to cut you off I'm so
sorry but I did want to ask you I forgot
to do this so so can you be a Muslim can
you be a Muslim and say that Allah is
your father and you're his son can you
be musl you can but you be you'll be an
innovation it'll be an innovation like
it won't take it will be an innovation
it depends on what you mean by exactly
what do you mean by that if they believe
if they believe that Allah I want to
make something clear there's something
there's an elephant in the room that
we're missing cuz you just quoted to us
verses from the Old Testament to show a
level of coherency between the Old
Testament and the New Testament there is
but the reality of the matter is even
you in your theology I let me ask you a
simple question those passages that you
quoted that refer to others as children
of God do you believe they're children
of God Like Jesus no uh no Jesus is the
begotten son that's a different oh see
begotten you believe he but listen yeah
you see you see the discrepancy here so
there's a discrepancy here even in you
so you should not be using those verses
as reference to show a level of
connection between them and Jesus what's
the dis in their in the in their
childhood no because you're saying Jesus
is begotten they're not begotten so no
they're not the same so you
differentiate between not only that not
only that you know not that just thing
sorry Avery those people the children of
Israel if they called the father the
father are are the same father like
Jesus's father or are they different he
said no so you see see you see when
Jesus wasn't father you're saying it's
different and when the father calls him
son he's different son but when it's the
children of Israel their sunship is
different to them calling them the
father but with Jesus a whole different
C you're given exception you say no with
Jesus it's specific when he says father
it's his actual father or literal
begotten and when he says the son is the
actual son but when it comes to the
others like um Moses so many other
people saying is this just to add on
because there's one thing you said I
just want to add on you said that the
the Islam came and distorted the whole
thing very simple question all the
prophets that came from Adam from Adam
to Moses did any of them believe in the
Trinity I would say yes okay can you
bring me a single bring me a single
evidence because you you're now
confronting the Jews and the Muslims so
please tell me because we say the
prophet Muhammad was in line with all
the prophets that came he said worship
alone there is nothing like him Adam and
all the prophets from De do were
consistent in the message of the Prophet
Muhammad only your Jesus even youres in
the Bible doesn't even say that so what
evidence do you have to say that Islam
came with something new that all the
prophets were they had the Trinity the
Holy Spirit the son the Islam came with
the prophet Muhammad and said no no no
no more son do you have evidence to
prove that these prophets before Jesus
believes in the Trinity just one just
one last question yeah yeah absolutely
so yes so it's it's not just that it's
the there's the disconnect with God
being father but yes within the essence
of God you know uh you know Islam has a
sort of a Unitarian view of God like
he's only a singular person while Mo
let's say Moses for example because you
I want to be specific to what you asked
Moses who wrote the Torah he taught that
God was
multi-personality Al Yahweh and divine
yet he's distinct from the father and
then Moses taught that's exod by the way
that's Exodus 3 then Moses Tau Genesis
one you the spirit of God so you have
this you have which which Jews believe
which Jews believe that these are
different Essences of God which which
Rabbi which Rabbi quote me one Rabbi
that believes that Moses believed that
this one God that they believe in with
us by the way the Jews and the Muslims
we have very very very similar there's
some things that they have about slept
and rested but what I'm saying is
Christians are the only ones that's odd
so can you tell me a single Rabbi that
said that Moses and all the other
prophets before believed in different
Essences of gods the way you guys do
okay so just just a quick correction
it's not different Essences it's
different persons right different hypo
okay different persons yeah what
different persons okay tell me a single
Rabbi that believe this single Jewish
person yeah I got you so have you heard
of Daniel
boern no okay so or so you got Daniel
boern and you got Benjamin summer these
are Jewish Scholars not okay Jewish
Scholars who are Jewish that believe
what that that believe that the Trinity
is actually in line with Judaism it's a
it's a Jewish belever let me let me just
get this right so one second there are
Jewish people it's like me saying there
are Muslims who believe that Trinity is
in live with Islam I'm a disbeliever no
that's not how can I be a Muslim how can
I be a Muslim and say trinity is in line
with
Islam your Muslim is not your
bloodline Jew by your blood oh no one
second you're saying okay you're saying
they're ethnically Jew yes oh I'm
talking about religiously Jew I'm talk
Rabbi I'm saying a rabbi no no I'm
saying Rabbi no they don't need they
believe
in no no no one second I'm saying a Jew
who follows Judaism and the Mosaic law
who believes who believes that God has
different per is different persons
persons yeah Daniel boern Benjamin
summer Alan Seagal these are not
Christians okay no these are not okay
we're going to do is this is this is
online I know you're recording this I'm
going to check it and if why you saying
okay no problem I'm going to check I'm
going to check this information and if
what you're saying is not true you're
being intellectually dishonest because
no je that I've come across they
outright reject that God has persons
Essence they don't they don't even
mention his name
listen from Summer none of this makes a
difference for us in reality to be
honest
with it doesn't but I'm going to what
I'm going to do is even it said even I
know it doesn't matter but I know
Judaism in J there's no way they believe
this the persons and the essence none of
them it goes against Rel can I give you
a reference Ali just really quick so
remember Benjamin summer is one of the
names I mentioned if you go to his book
it's called bodies of God bodies of God
okay he gives like so if you go to his
book look up his quote what he talks
about the Trinity uh the glory of God he
he breaks that stuff down and he breaks
down how you know uh the trinity or God
having multiple persons is not a
non-jewish
belief what you mean what's his name
like you know the hypostasis like within
the substance and essence of God there
are there's a there there are distinct
hypostasis or persons father son Holy
Spirit or what they would say is they
would say you have h y you have Yahweh
yeah you have Yahweh you have his word
and his spirit so that which contradict
God is not a body I want to find out who
this is just one second
who is who is who is this person what's
his
name oh so this one is Benjamin summer
that I'm quoting I'm talking about and
what's his bookies of God bodies of God
okay what he is what this man abl
SCH yeah he's a Jew okay okay we're
checking okay so when you say different
bodies I just want to understand so they
say he just repeat again it's a body
second you say the spirit his book his
book is called by of God um and he talks
about he goes you know kind of in detail
of how there you know it's not foreign
to Jewish belief that there is you know
multiplicity within the unity of Yahweh
so so he gives so he he's he's an
academic okay but what I'm saying is so
by way so he gives Divinity to these fre
he's not a
rabbi he's not a
rabbi he's a
Jew you understand Jews professor who
are atheist it doesn't matter aist he's
in Judaism I know I know but I'm saying
there are Jewish who are Jewish people
who are atheist it doesn't matter we ask
you he ask you a specific thing is there
a Jew Rabbi who said this that's his
question see I think not Professor there
are Jewish professors who I know they
are they are
atheists the Reas the reason no the
reason rabbis go to his Seminary guys
like no come on come does matter Avery
Avery Avery let me tell you something I
know Muslims who come and say some mad
stuff about Allah yeah just because he
has a title yeah academics they say
stuff like you know uh some great God is
not in this world the world the point
the the reason I'm saying this the
reason I'm saying this I know very well
I've spoken to so many Jewish people
rabbis who come to the park Speakers
Corner you know very well yeah you know
very well none of them ever believe this
I know very fundamentally that none of
them have a ever believed that the
prophets this is why I asked you the
message of the Adam and all the other
prophets that came before were in line
with the prophet Muhammad's message that
God is one that's why the Jews do not
believe in you not a body and he's not a
body he's not do you get it so that's
why the prophet Muhammad's message was
in line with all the other prophets that
came it's only Christianity that's the
reason why the Jews and the Muslims
they'll agree on one thing that we do
not believe God is the creation and
that's what we different about Avery
thank you very much I know it's going to
go online and we just recently found out
you know yeah you've done videos Etc
it's totally fine I know you're
recording it's totally fine all I'm just
saying is you can join us after Ramadan
because we're doing a fundraiser for
sure but yeah I I appreciate it say
thank you it's like what they say not a
flesh like us as a human being with a
flesh and
things I just want to say thank you to
all three of you guys you guys are
respectful you let me talk thank you for
engaging appreciate you guys for letting
me on I we need something from you we
need something from you what's
your every listen
listen every tell the people to donate
towards this project yeah yeah say to
the people because something which is
good yeah tell the people toate towards
this project because this project teach
people how to pray they prate like Jesus
how how Jesus prate to God we do the
same thing the same as the old brother
prophets tell the people you know since
we allowed you we didn't allow no one
like you with the time so at least in
return we expect from you effect F to
tell the people to do that will you do
that one second will you do that yeah
I'll tell them to to to donate to
whoever is giving the gospel and
spreading the message of no not the
gospel I'm talking about the
gospel no no theil yes but not the but
not the but not the
Bible which is lost unfortunately yeah
we're messing around we're messing
around but thank you every it was a
pleasure thank you really app thanks
guys
for